from the Ohio State University to now
the Los Angeles chargers he is Joey Bosa
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Joey I'm good how are you I'm doing fine
I am doing absolutely fine everything
seems to be great in the Bosa world huh
these days this weekend
is this the best weekend that you have
had what's the best weekend football
weekend you you as the Bosa brothers
have had prior to this one yeah I'd have
to say that this one this one probably
takes the cake here why is that
statistically was speaking in that
nonsense when you were lining up in
Chicago Joey and times tickin down and
the Bears took a knee did that surprise
you honestly I kind of I didn't really
realize how much time was left I kind of
assumed that it was you know down to the
last seconds because they were III I
don't know I was I was just so
demoralized that they got down the field
if you feel go but I wasn't really
thinking about anything else no other
than the fact that I hope together they
miss and look swim away throw on sand
you know didn't think now I hear yeah I
mean before we get to the whole
demoralized sense I guess that then when
you realized after the game the
situation I guess in which true Biscay
took a knee did that surprise you yeah
yeah I guess I didn't really understand
the decision though they could've run a
couple more players got a little closer
I don't know if that's true Biscay
decision or what whoever made that
decision but yeah I guess the big
probably could have attacked it a little
differently well I mean and again it's
interesting that I would take get a
perspective from somebody on the other
side of the line and certainly somebody
whose job it is is to disrupt plays that
the coach Matt Negi said and this has
been a part of the conversation in
Chicago since is that everybody knew
that they were gonna run
and that would lead to a loss of yardage
that he didn't want to risk did you yes
when you lined up were you preparing for
a run in that situation oh yeah
definitely preparing for a run
probably that for them just to pound it
get a few yards closer and have a little
better shot at making it but uh I guess
that logic makes sense well and then
when you say that you were kind of
demoralized over the fact that the
Chargers had gotten as far into your
territory as they did did that was that
just the the general situation of the
game or was that just compounded by what
was happening to your team in the
previous weeks leading up to that it was
just tough because you know I felt like
we we kind of put the nail in the coffin
with the sack and then they heard
offense got backed up and then they had
to punt and I kind of I had a feeling
that the game a little bit was in our
hands and all we had to do was stop them
and they were driving down the field and
yeah it was it was tough I kind of just
in my mind hoped and thought that the
game was over at that point and yeah it
was tough then obviously with the
addition of weeks prior and the things
that have been happening it's also tough
but again you got the W you got the
winning now here you got it yes and you
got the chance to come home and you've
got the Packers and Aaron Rodgers
what has challenged as he present to you
Joey
I mean his arm strength
kind of throws he made last week and
he's been doing this whole career it's
tough it's tough to defend against you
obviously know that a guy like that's
gonna make plays here and they're just
gonna try to limit it they have a good
ol line I haven't really lost much I'm
gonna start watching the sound do you
talk to somebody like him Joey do you do
if you do get him on the ground do you
say something yeah is that something you
do to Rogers yeah I don't know maybe
maybe a little something I'm usually I'm
usually not saying much so cubies but uh
yeah I think Rogers
there's a little bit of respect did you
say something okay yeah I mean so no
championship belt if you put him down on
the ground nothing like that
depends on the scenario I want to feel
comfortable that we're gonna pull away
with the win from so I'm gonna be yeah I
don't want to get in his head and have
him any more motivated to try to beat us
as you know Joey
your brother has set the sack
celebration bar very high I do I think
he's the clubhouse leader in that when
he planted the flag on Baker Mayfield
I'm wondering did he talk about this
with you in preparation I mean it was no
I was a little confused at first what he
was going for but he said that he took a
friend of us Tommy about it before and
that was his idea and then he literally
planted a flag after the game on the
turf yeah in Sanford yeah I don't really
like these flag plants that aren't
actually giving you into the ground you
know but I think I get a medal by
digging some dirt but I think the I
think the idea was you know it got home
and and it divided it delighted the
entire Buckeye Nation I'm wondering when
you saw that what did you did you call
your brother up walk me through that
process after that well I was watching
so I didn't call him I didn't call him
right away but we talked we talked
pretty regularly pretty much every day
we're checking in with each other so
yeah I talked to him about it and then
he told me that it was Tommy's idea and
it seems like again he's taken to this
NFL thing pretty pretty well
yeah I'm wondering do you think he's
Defensive Player of the Year right now
Joey uh there's definitely an argument
for it I don't see why not
we defensive rescue here but you know
it's no surprise to many have explained
why why is that - I expected it you
expected it right from the guy me but
you also know what a leap it is to go
from one level to the next he's why is
that walk me through that one just the
way it plays you're seeing it now is
really ok Joey Bosa here on the Rich
Eisen show tell me about the Chargers
annual trick-or-treat trail for
pediatric cancer patients that's going
down this week last year at dressed up
is Bobby Boucher I have to round up a
costume tonight but what do you got a
nice you go I'm not sure what I learned
and I thought it's nice you get a bunch
of kids around the facility we do last
year we did some decorating some cookies
and stuff it's just good to put a smile
on their faces okay you know have them
have a have a night of distraction okay
and you you're going there and just
hanging out with the kids and
celebrating Halloween yeah we're seeing
video of you with the the Bobby Boucher
number nine on now from last year I've
got an idea for you Joey oh why don't
you go is Jim Harbaugh okay that's a
good one
what do you think we're a big L on my
hub no no your one letter off your one
letter off Joey mm-hmm your one off
that's an M you know you got to move a
little bit further down the alphabet
okay you know I'm feeling good cuz I bet
Jerome Bettis this past week I'm
Michigan Notre Dame but I'm gonna hold
off on on offering anything your way
right now Joey you know yeah I don't
know if you wanna I don't know if you
want to challenge the book I believe in
my team but I got to tell you and I do
want to ask you this before I let you go
on with your your Tuesday here
this kid chase young you know when you
watch a broadcast sometimes an analyst
will have to circle somebody or they'll
point to say that's where this kid is on
the field I don't need that with him I
see exactly where he is when he lines up
how good is this kid in your estimation
jelly yeah he's great I mean you see the
similarities and our argument and my
brother's game all coming from coach
Johnson obviously I mean he's a
mastermind he's unbelievable though how
he understands passion you know he's 100
over the years it's uh once he gets an
athletic body I can you know move the
way chase and other guys can he could
really mold it into whatever he wants oh
yeah it's uh it's really impressive to
see what Chase is doing for sex that's
awesome so I mean what are they doing
box I'm with the tight end milk ship
they're crazy
well there was one instance where they
decided he try and use his speed against
him by just not blocking him at all I'm
throwing to the side and that did not
chip him and and know that he was too
fast to use his speed against him I was
in soon but see Joey I'm using all my
professionalism right now to talk about
somebody who is worthy of the the
conversation especially after you you
say that there should be an L on the Hat
of Jim it's it's it's all good it's all
good
hey you know the rivalry I do know it
and I just wonder why why why can't
oh hi Oh state part me the Ohio State
fans say the name of the school I mean
I'm and not even type out the M I mean I
say you could find plenty of instances
just because Joey thanks for the call
man appreciate it you got to keep ballin
out and enjoy the you know making these
kids nights it's pretty much what you
and your teammates do will do thank you
got that Joey Bosa Chargers defensive
end you're in the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on Br
or download the Rich Eisen show app